Welcome everybody to the cutters clinic cancer membership site
We just are excited to
Create this for you and please understand that you should come back to it on a regular basis
It is going to be a fluid living site will be adding things you'll see under the zoom call list and things
Obviously, we're going to be adding those on a weekly basis. So
And it's a living site meeting that you will be helping us
Add information in the submit a question section you can submit some general questions that you think would be helpful for everybody that we can make a video on
And we'll do our best to accommodate
But we want this this site
To be a site where where the general public cannot access. So it's going to be more specific things to our cancer patients
and what might be
Something that we won't share
Beyond that. So please do not give out your password to
Our non-patients. This is supposed to be a site just for our patients
Especially when we put our zoom calls on there that people
Staying might be present in such that
Were their voice or their specific question of their struggles that we ask that you just keep this personal
On this site you're going to see different
Pages for frequently asked questions and videos on those zoom calls the rife help etc
So scroll through those pages the each one of these pages may be changing on a weekly daily monthly basis
So make sure you keep up to date and look at those
The whole purpose of this is to help you make better decisions and become more informed because we believe that
The more educated you are the more knowledgeable you are in in everything you're going to be able to make better decisions
Just come from the belief that we're called to
Be constantly using our brain and educating ourselves and becoming knowledgeable in all things
So we want you to make the best decisions possible through your prayer time
That's what the whole purpose of this is so welcome to the site scroll through it have fun with it
and in the
In the questions section if you have some comments and things that we could do to improve it
We'll do our best to do that because we want this to be your site. Thanks